[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مع مشاهدينا الى جوله جديده في
الصحف العالميه والعربيه والتي نبداها مع
القرار الالماني الذي بارسال دبابات
القتاليه الى كيف ونبدا
الالمانيه التي تقول بعد شهور من الجدل
والضغط وفقا المستشار الفوز اخيرا على
الاستجابه الى طلب كيف القرار قد التخذ
والحكومه الالمانيه ستسمح ايضا لدول اخرى
بما في ذلك بولندا ارسال دبابات ليوبارد
الى اوكرانيا
ياتي هذا القرار بالتزامن مع اعلان الصحف
الامريكيه عن قرار
لجوبايدن بارسال دبابات ابرامز الى كيف
هذا القرار الذي يمكن اطفاء الطبع الرسمي
عليه اليوم وفقا صحيفه
جورنال الامريكيه
وصحيفه ذا جارجن البريطانيه علقت على
الموضوع وعنوان
الذي اتخذته برلين بارسال دبابات الى كيف
قرار تاريخي اما صحيفه
الفرنسيه
[موسيقى]
على كيف تتلقى اخيرا كيف دبابات ليوبارت
القتاليه اللي بغثيو ايضا تحدثت عن مدينه
ترسل موسكو العديد مرتزقه فاجنر على امل
الاستيلاء على هذه المدينه حيث تهاجمها
مضر اكثر من خمسه اشهر وفقا لمسؤول امريكي
فان لو است- حتى لو استثمرت كيف ما ورد
كبيره في الدفاع عن هذه المدينه الا انه
كلما طال امد القتال هناك زادت فرصه
القوات الروسيه
المتفوقه في العدد والمجهزه بشكل افضل
بالمدفعيه همم ستكون لها الفرصه اكبر في
الاستله عليها لكن هذا حسب المسؤول
الامريكي لن يمثل نقطه تحول استراتيجيه او
رئيسيه في الحرب تحف واشنطن الان
الاوكرانيين على الاستعداد لاستئناف
الهجمات على نطاق واسع في نهايه الشتاء
والى موضوع عن اخر
ولمن التي صحيفه اليمن التي تتحدث عن تونس
وتعنوان في تونس الاتحاد العام
الاساسيه للشغل يدعو الى اضراب لمده 48
ساعه في قطاع النقل احتجاجا على ابتزاز
صندوق النقد الدولي في سياق سياسيا شديد
التوتر اما صحيفه العرب
فتعنوان الاضرابات اسلوب فوضوي من اتحاد
الشغل لفرض اجندته على الحكومه
التونسيه وغضب شعبي على تنفيذ اضرابات
عشوائيه تزيد من معاناه التونسيين الصحيفه
تنقل عن مراقبين ان الاضرابات المتتاليه
في هذا الوضع الصعاب الذي يعيشه التونسيون
لا شك انها ستحول الغضب الشعبي نحو اتحاد
الشغل بالرغم من الشعارات التي يدفعها
للدفاع التي يرفعها للدفاع عن التونسيين
وحول محدوديه القدره الشرائيه لكنه بدلا
من ان يراعي ظروفهم الصعبه فانه يزيد
عليهم من خلال اضرابات عشوائيه حسب
الصحيفه والى موضوع اخر وصحيفه الشرق
الاوسط التي تحدثت عن لبنان وعنوانه لبنان
يغلي على نار البيطار
والدولار تقول الصحيفه تزايد الغليان
السياسي والاقتصادي في لبنان مع بلوغ سعر
صرف الدولار الامريكي رقما قياسيا جديدا
يهدد اللبنانيين بمزيد من الصعوبات
المعيشيه وايضا مع الاسماء المستجده التي
افرزتها عوده قاضي التحقيق طارق البيطار
في ملف انفجار
بيروت طارق البيطار الذي حدد مواعيد
الاستجواب المدعى عليهم من سياسيين واميين
وعسكريين وقدد
وصحيفه لو موند تحدثت عن عوده اطفال
الجهاديين اييي الى فرنسا حيث اعيد اثنين
واعيد 32 الطفلا وخمسه عشره امراه فرنسيه
من المخيمات السوريه الى فرنسا يوم
الثلاثاء وبهذه الاعاده يرتفع الى
295 عدد القاصرين العائدين من المنطقه
وزيره الدوله الفرنسيه لشؤون الاطفال
اشارت الى ان هؤلاء القصه ليسوا مسؤولين
عن تطرف في ابائهم ولم يختاروا الذهاب الى
هناك فهم فرنسيون وقصر ولهم الحق في
الحمايه
بهذا مشاهدينا نصل الى ختام هذه الجوله في
الصحف لهذا اليوم شكرا لكم على المتابعه
والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]